citizens of the reject Nation welcome
once again to Our Last of Us episode 6
this time reaction review experience
Tara Erickson joining me once again how
you doing Tara I'm here and I'm in
leopard you are you look so cool right
now right you should be in the next
Wonder Woman film please absolutely we
are the noobs my friends ever grateful
to Greg for pairing us together because
this has been such a blast and ever
grateful to you guys as well for keeping
it that way so uh keep up the good work
and as always if you want to get
notified every time one of these
reactions or anything else interesting
on the channel drops hit the Subscribe
button and
about
the bell ring the bell and don't forget
to leave a like on this video that helps
arguably the most out of anything and if
you want to get the full experience all
the things that get cut out of these
reaction highlights come on over to
patreon.com the real rejects sync up
with your own copy of The Last of Us and
enjoy the experience alongside Tara and
I don't forget as well to check out Greg
and Andrew's Last of Us reactions for
the pro Gamers perspective and uh if you
want to support the channel in a
different way maybe check out our little
merch shop especially this brand new who
influences the influencers shirt that
Greg designed isn't that sweet Tara this
is going that's for you here with me
good all right I think we're ready to go
let's let's do this let's let's jump
into it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God please learn this on guitar so
you can play it I'm gonna learn it you
should I think there are probably tabs
out there and then I'll come in as the
yellow fungus I know I still and then I
could all do like an interpretive dance
yeah this could go viral you you gotta
work on it viral viral
or fungal
oh time Jump a mile outside of Boston
baby wolves and baby rabbits oh it's a
symbol
for the Lost Innocence
and the gun
oh take the gun out two fingers only put
it Out Of Reach
I'm looking for my brother oh I ain't
seen him I haven't told you what he
looks like you look anything like you
bit no I ain't seen him I need you to
tell us where we are we're somewhere
here exactly where and your answer
better be the same as your wife's oh
you're telling the truth yeah
are you telling me the truth
well you found a great place to hide I
guess
anywhere people used to be you can't go
there no more so you haven't heard the
name Tommy nope
we get those in the summer
not to pass the river death
some Infected some not if your brother
is west of the river he's gone oh boy
you're not gonna scare us you scared him
foreign
I like those too
oh just the cold air all of a sudden uh
you're having a panic attack Joel
there's some caves along the river we'll
set up camp there across in the morning
she's stolen two rabbits we can get our
own rabbits you're gonna teach me how
yeah
hunting Montage yay
hmm
can I have some no what just to warm up
let her have some
sharp kids just to warm up
so gross
she immediately grows a five o'clock
shadow
say we find the fireflies it all works
where are you going what are you doing
an old farmhouse some land a ranch cool
yeah
I would raise sheep they're quiet
I don't know what they're told sell the
wool make your own coats Joel I read
everything I could in the school library
Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin Jim Lovell do
you know who my favorite is it's Charlie
Ryan
best astronaut name ever surely and
don't call me Shirley it'll work right
the vaccine
it's a little late to start wondering uh
you should see the debate now get some
sleep
dream of
sheep ranches on the moon oh
that's a sweet way to say we'll stick
together kid no I really want to see a
sheep Ranch on the moon at the end of
this show that's what I'm is
foreshadowing Tara what are you talking
about
I woke up early you were passed out so I
took second watch you can't do things
like this but I can
hey man I'm a natural
you are of this world
God that makes me cold just looking at
it I love it I'll take all the cold too
cold John it's beautiful though it's so
beautiful it is it is the river of death
still no people
y'all should find some all-white outfits
though you're wandering in the snow and
dressed like Andrew W.K out here
Boston is just beautiful gotta go there
someday I know we're not still in Boston
in case anybody wondered about that joke
down
[Laughter]
nice put that in the pun book look at
that River
Hey Joe
what if this is the river of death
what makes you say that oh cause the dam
is holding back the
uh oh no oh no hello nope okay we're
looking for any trouble we're just
passing through
drop the gun oh dang it you think five
steps back how about we just talk this
through how about you shut the [__] up
okay that easy
Coral she's still got a gun you've been
near infected there's no infected out
here the hell they're right
no no no no
fact that he will smell it and he will
rip you up
oh boy
thank you
like I said we'll just move on
now her
damn it you faked us out dog
train you to do that oh boy okay
[Music]
he can't sniff out special blood
oh boy
oh Joel Don't Panic dude don't panic oh
God
oh thank God
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's lovely
what are you doing out here just looking
for my brother it's all nothing more we
haven't seen any brothers here
or sisters or otherwise what's your name
Joel
[Music]
oh God they know
foreign
the operation it's funny how the past
becomes the present too this does feel
just like an old west white Fort or
something
[Music]
Snowman
oh my God what oh Thomas oh
[Music]
damn I wasn't expecting to see him
oh guys come here to save you
[Laughter]
oh these guys
oh
wow that's like summer camp and also
that made me teary-eyed it's beautiful
there's more if you need it thank you
ma'am
been a while since we've had a proper
meal actually I don't think I've ever
had a proper meal
let's mind our manners
what
what's wrong with you what about her
manners kids around here don't usually
look or talk like you right well maybe
I'll teach them
I think maybe y'all got a little off on
the wrong foot who's gonna have our guys
kill us well you got to be real careful
about who we let in this place well you
got a couple of nine-year-olds shooting
themselves out there
yeah
we're grateful for your hospitality and
all but it'd be nice to have a moment
here maybe just for family
oh Maria is family dang don't say
congrats
manners Joel congrats
I'll give them a moment
it's a 700 but I found a variable Power
Scope sub MOA and headshot those folks
from a half mile out you teach me how no
we can't
how do you keep this place quiet
carefully it's not advertising what we
have staying off the radio we draw power
from a dam got that working a couple
years ago this place actually [__]
works
all we need now is the moon everything
you see in our town
greenhouses livestock all shared
Collective ownership
so uh communism leave this place
immediately that's our newest one a
couple months old you want a pet her ah
what's your name
I love Shimmer some new clothes we can
put them in the empty house across the
street from us yeah pretty much
untouched and so three but it's got the
Heat going in it do worse oh trust me we
have been we've been doing fine oh
oh Joel thanks for still giving a [__]
about me
working on raising some Hogs too
once we get bacon I mean what's even
left
so how's Tess
oh she's fine oh all right and the kid
she's the daughter of some Firefly
muckety muck no they got a base down at
the University of Eastern Colorado a
week's Ride Shop
oh boy yeah I can't go what cause your
wife won't let you no she's the one who
kept you off the radio is that why you
stopped messaging me back oh
they didn't have to take me in but they
did and all they asked is that I follow
that rule I'm your brother they're very
protective of this place and you just
got here if you knew the [__] that I've
been through Tommy trying to find you
these last few months I'm gonna be a
father oh
of course
but I don't know why
feel like I'd be a good dad
I believe in you I guess we'll find out
that's all you got what else am I
supposed to say just because life
stopped for you it doesn't mean it has
to stop for me
oh boy go grab some supplies and be out
of your hair in the morning
oh dude you just got here
gotta open yourself up to someone Joel
[Music]
the poll
it's Christmas Story all over again
oh no it looks just like her
oh Sarah
oh my
gross
[Laughter]
oh she's the best that's great
oh oh in memoriam you were looking at
the little Memorial Tommy made I'm sorry
about your kids it's okay
just Kevin Sarah was Joel's daughter
laughs
Revelation look I'm not going to ask you
what you're doing with him good but
there are clearly things you don't know
about Joel oh like how he used to kill
people I know about that and Tommy did
it too are you worried about him
Tommy was following Joel the way you are
now well maybe I'm smarter than Tommy no
offense
[Laughter]
that'd be a super eggplant coat
the movies movies
what let's do this oh God Ellie's gonna
stay forever Tony's you know Tony
DeForest
that's nice
I'm an actor too Nothing Like Richard
Dreyfus for the apocalypse this ride to
the university as it is that mission
just just pair and do what you do you've
had people go that way and come back and
all of them what is this
I'll Trust she's immune she got infected
but she didn't get sick that was months
ago months she's in
oh boy it was Marlene she hired us to
smuggle her to some fireflies it went
bad test got bit uh there you go you
know she saved my life there
from another kid five years ago I would
have destroyed him
but she had to shoot him to save me I
saw a Man kill his own brother
and today I thought that dog was gonna
tear apart because it smelled something
on her and all I did was stand there I
couldn't think of anything he said just
oh so far oh Joe yeah PTSD man I have
dreams
remember
I just know that when I wake up
I've lost something oh it's all I've
ever done
failure you want me to take her I'm just
going to get her killed I know it Joe
I mean it's what you took off on me
right to make up for the things we did
oh
you're younger than me you're still
strong you said it yourself you'll come
back you have to take her Ellie will
never let that happen yeah Tommy you're
the only one I trust if anyone else sees
those bites on her what's under her skin
so shoot her to the last thing I'll ever
ask
oh
Bravo performance yeah what a scene I'll
take her out of dawn oh boy oh boy
something feels ominous and not right
right now
yeah I don't feel like this is gonna go
off as planned
we all they had to worry about boys
movies
and which shirt goes with which skirt
the grand time you missed out on I came
here to talk to you no why are you still
here if you're gonna ditch me ditch me
oh I made this decision for your own
good he knows the area better than I do
you don't give a [__] about me or not of
course I do and what are you so afraid
of exactly that
I'm not her you know
oh
all right Ellie I'm sorry about your
daughter Joel
I have lost people too
you have no idea what loss is
everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me yeah
everybody except for you
so don't tell me that I'd be safe with
somebody else because the truth is I
would just be more scared
you're not my daughter
I'm not sure as hell ain't your dad
now come down
we're going our separate ways oh what
dude
oh my God I get it but also I get it
come on I'm mad right now I can't keep
pushing people away gotta accept the
progress of time what the frick else are
you gonna do Joel
[Music]
to watch
here we go there's no way that that wife
is gonna let him Tommy go
yes some shoes got a drop in control
as it should be
what a lovely cabin this needs to be
like a last minute run to the airport in
a rom-com and Joel is like I'm waiting
with you wait that needs to that needs
to happen go to her Joel yeah I came
here to steal one of these horses and go
I would have gave you one that was 30
minutes ago and I guess you deserve a
choice I still think you'd be better off
with Tom let's go
hahaha
yep yes sir
naughty Oaks Big Brother
[Music]
go with God
take some whiskey with you
sure gonna need it
[Music]
oh practice oh fun you're flinching the
target's too small I made it bigger than
I should have I'm not quenching rifle
just sucks
you squeeze the trigger like you love it
it's gentle but steady nice and slow
you're gonna shoot this thing or get it
pregnant
dang
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love it got that a-hole
beautiful shot I guess it was an H hole
there but this building that's right
houses stores that kind of thing
we were called contractors it's a
contractor
that's pretty cool so cool we're cool
everybody loved contractors
that's right man
very important job
should be more celebrated roof is an
important job I don't know what Tommy
was so afraid of still time to find out
still come to find out
[Laughter]
I don't want to hang out with Ellie I
don't see any fireflies though they're
probably in the middle
safer
oh damn we're here I don't want a sheep
Ranch actually I mean if the dealers I
can do anything that's the deal when I
was a kid I wanted to be a singer
yes yes uh sing a song It's Gonna Echo
so well in these Chambers
will you sing it for me later
I want to save the [__] world matters
the least you can do for me the
Acoustics were perfect right back there
are those monkeys
from the old Labs oh
[Music]
okay no guards gun
yeah get it out
just the growth alone there
arm up
[Music]
no harm better befall this horse
I know The Walking Dead traumatized me
from that
[Music]
a little bit of a sailing drip left over
yeah I would take some of that
there are definitely doctors here
there's a packing list something to make
before moving
they just left
were they headed to Salt Lake City did
it say it's cool like in a game when you
grab a document like the ways they they
put little moments that feel kind of
like a gameplay thing yeah subtly
[Music]
damn you monkeys at least it ain't
clickers yeah no fireflies either
maybe in all that research they turned
into monkeys monkey could rip you apart
yeah was that a baboon a Capuchin a
chimp three hours later he's named all
the monkeys
that's where they went
the pins lead there better facilities
I don't know
oh boys no don't are they gonna steal a
horse
what are these Raiders
[Music]
[__] [__] [__]
ah
conserve
whoa adrenaline
ow
okay it's a railroad spike
oh okay belt belt I don't know of course
damn it [__]
Ellie's gonna do it come on Ellie come
on Ellie come on now you have to save
Joel oh Jesus shoot shoot shoot oh God
yes yes
oh my God
I think we're safe we gotta stop the
bleeding yeah
I hope you know how to sew come on come
on come on don't open your eyes
open your eyes Joy you gotta get up
Joe
oh no no no no no no no no
[Music]
what is this song are you trying to make
me scream cry right now
oh shut up
no
[Music]
why
look I know it's I I don't actually know
I don't think Joe can be dead but also
they'll put you through stuff in shows
and games like these they they'll count
on you saying that to yourself and then
pull the rug out from under you there's
no way
he had to have taught her like first aid
but also why wouldn't she like shoving
some tissue in there to stop the
bleeding yeah and I gotta have like a
suture or something in there in their
kit you would think so him anything can
happen
why what a what a what an experience
I feel emotionally drained same
now let's review the episode yeah
oh my gosh
yeah right dude this show is like roller
coaster after roller coaster absolutely
like wow this has been fascinating and I
like I really enjoyed this episode
because this one I mean you know by the
time you get to the end there is more
Intrigue and Peril and suspense but so
much of this was you know there is an
ominous feeling around you don't know
exactly who to trust or or how to kind
of
apply you know the the commune
especially to the rest of the world and
kind of you know Orient yourself in
terms of how you're supposed to feel
it's very lovely and so much of this
episode you spend there and so much of
it is traveling without you know the
immediate dangers and so a lot of this
was like really nice to spend time in
yeah and to just kind of drink in
visually for the scenery and for the
atmosphere
um but yeah like the way they also
extrapolated the emotion and the way
that they've you know kind of been
almost like nomadically between these
episodes showing you
just like these different characters
lives as you have Joel and Ellie kind of
through lining at all I think has been
really interesting and very rich you
know and very effecting yeah
you see how much they have grown
together which is why I was glad the one
he showed up towards the end because I
was like there's no way you can't split
them up just like I'm saying right now
he can't be dead I know hug
I really like though that they take so
much time
um just showing us like how they live
and going through things and seeing them
just like talk like skip to they're on
the horse and they're talking about all
these different things Joel teaching
Ellie about how the world used to be
um and I think it's uh it's so sweet
and then it just really shows us how
closed off Joel is where he's like
you're right even after Ellie says all
these nice things he's like you're right
you're not my daughter I'm sure as hell
not your dad yeah and he just like
leaves don't get close to me yeah like
you think that
it's gonna he might just like open up
sort of like he said uh I'll have a
sheep farm on the moon that's like his
little way but it keeps it's there's
that threshold with him where it's like
no he he'll take one step over and then
he'll like 10 10 steps back yeah it's
like it's like the yeah yeah it's like
he's got a line of closeness and if you
get too close and too you know
reminiscent of of especially the life
before and and what the feelings must
have been you know just having that
relationship still you know alive and
vital with Sarah like they do a really
nice job of of having those debates and
those character responses in a way that
never feels contrived or feels like the
plot demands its uh you know like the
the reunion between him and Tommy yeah
in this I thought was really nicely
handled like you can feel
both the the brotherly love that they
have but also the tension from so much
time from the things they did at the
beginning of the outbreak uh and the
ways they've both really changed and
it's funny because we've seen you know
Tommy through Joel's perspective so much
in you know the intervening episodes
between the first one and now and I
really love the way that they kind of
get you know it's like we saw Tommy last
before everything went to [__] and now
we're seeing him again in a different
place where it does feel like all this
time has passed and he has grown and and
changed even though we haven't spent all
that time with him yeah um so I just
hats off to both the the actors
especially but also the writing like I
think the writing is really thoughtful
and does well to you know keep you
grounded in the world but also engrossed
in the experiences characters are having
you know yeah yeah yeah they did a great
a great job of like showing us how his
brother has moved on without him saying
it he never said like hey man like they
do in other TV shows hey man look I've
moved on I've moved like they do that
all the time and I hate it so much
that's like I'm like oh God come on and
so of course in the show they do a
really good job of not being
expositional they just like show us the
stuff and it's it was um also nicely
surprising like when he grabbed her hand
it was like oh oh yeah all right
um and I also like that he he didn't
tell him right away like oh she's
pregnant I'm expecting a child it sort
of had to come out yeah
um yeah out of like a desperate moment
because there's so much yeah of just
like life development that he's had that
then is forced into
these brief exchanges yeah instead of
you know having a nice dinner and like
talking about life and then having it
come up it's more just like okay you got
your mission so I I have to use this
information functionally rather than
emotionally uh you know to sort of say
why I cannot take on this this risk
necessarily yeah and just those those
debates and the way they realize the
commune I thought like the commune is so
lovely you know and uh you just want to
spend you just want to hang out there
you just want to like spend a bunch of
time there and even the thing with the
couple at the beginning like I I like
it's like I get the sense
that throughout these episodes they're
probably doing things that yeah are are
game related you're probably going to
environments and and parts of the
country that you would Traverse in the
game but I feel like throughout each of
these episodes they will add or maybe
you know in the case of like a bill and
Frank vastly expand on
just other human characters and their
experiences so I love that you just have
this couple living remote you know out
off the land you know kind of almost you
know like they're they're like a Native
American couple so it's it's almost like
seeing them and then just thinking about
the Heritage there is interesting
because it almost seems like they're
sort of unbothered like like his wife is
just so chill you know and uh and just
the way that they interact with Joel and
Ellie and the way that they have that
sort of tense but completely relaxed
standoff yeah that's so great and and a
great opportunity for like a you know
the at least I didn't recognize the
woman but the the guy is like a
character actor you've seen in a bunch
of stuff and so like it's cool to have
you know
actors like that be able to show up on a
show like this leave an impression even
if it is just like a brief little scene
yeah and it was also as if to say their
life before the change of the world was
the same as it is then now that what
we're seeing in the present moment it's
like not much has changed for us yeah
they choose they chose to live that way
before the [__] came yeah lucky she
agreed to go out there with him because
it worked out and she did not want to I
love that scent and she's like I didn't
want to she's just sitting there like in
a rocking chair and it just took what
the second she said that I was like man
I bet you she just landed there in that
house out in the middle of nowhere and
was like I don't think I want to be this
secluded but then she just like at least
I have my rocking chair yeah like that's
just like her life and now yeah like the
world crashes and it's like all right
well hey I got the rocking chair I'm
doing better than most people yeah I
have earned the right to be so chill
yeah yeah a guy came with a gun I'll
make you some soup yes I love that too
you made soup and the whole thing about
like did you tell them did you tell them
the truth are you telling me the truth
like this is so great so good and uh and
yeah like I liked that the commune stuff
you know it's like you're constantly and
I think the walking dead it's
interesting to watch this show post
Walking Dead because there are ways in
which sure they're quite similar they're
drawing from similar cloth in terms of
motifs and and genres genre tropes and
elements and things like that
um although they are very different in
sensibility and so it's like in a The
Walking Dead kind of primed me to go
like okay somebody there's some evil
secret beneath this communist gotta be
something messed up about this and and
maybe maybe not Tommy but you know maybe
his wife or maybe somebody here is is
gonna be you know uh particularly vile
or terrible or do something to Joel or
Ellie or whatever and and they set you
up for that you know with that you know
don't go past the river you know there's
Dead Infected that we find dead people
like there there's some you know
Insidious or there's some you know uh
very just Dark Matter lying Beyond yeah
exactly like there's something sinister
out there be it human or otherwise don't
go there and then you get there and
you're like no this is like beautiful
yeah and that whole thing about like if
you hit just because you have a certain
reputation doesn't necessarily mean you
are that way and you kind of understand
you're like yeah I get why you would
want everyone to think that there's a
big bad lurking out there because
they're not gonna go there and then
you're gonna be fine you know like
you're gonna be relatively unbothered by
things and yeah just like really well
thought out and the way they weave it
all together with the travel is like
beautiful to look at is like beautiful
to just spend time it makes you want to
go travel yeah even despite like I like
that it's like there are moments between
I think that happens sometimes like you
have a zombie or a you know an outbreak
or whatever kind of horror tindered show
or movie and there's I feel like
sometimes a pressure to make it feel
like everything is kind of always
permeated by the bleakness whereas yeah
you know in a situation like this 20
years on yeah there there have to be in
between moments where things are just
kind of chill or Pleasant or beautiful
or you know anything in between and
those help to really then create that
contrast for when you see like when
you're out at the University and uh you
know it's things just feel wrong and off
and you're like okay now I'm very tense
again and it's cool because it allows
you
to kind of just react and have the
tension build
from your own suspicion just as much as
from what the show's actually giving you
yeah which is nice and also to think
about that people were saying once you
go past the river of death it's not
because people are dying it's because
they're staying in the commune yeah
unless they were stepped out it's
literally like now that you think about
they're you know they're not dead
they're just like oh yeah that's way
better I'm not going back yeah like
obviously this is where all the people
are the dead ones are probably just the
scavengers or people who aren't going to
you know who just want to plunder or
pillage you know exactly yeah which I
and I also like that they give you some
brevity when we when we land there
because in initially in the beginning
we're not sure exactly what's going to
happen and then you kind of have fun
times but then you like you said you
allow your emotions to kind of get to
you along with the very good music that
they have in this yeah uh that carries
us throughout to go like what is waiting
behind the corner yeah uh yeah it's they
do a great job of that yeah and the
tangibility to like it's so it's such a
relief when you know it's it's cathartic
when Joel and Tommy finally reunite and
it's such a relief when they're like
actually having a real meal and Ellie
gets to take another like probably her
second actual shower yeah in the whole
series yeah and and those moments too
I I I'm sure other things have done it
certainly but this show does a really
nice job of frequently kind of checking
in on that making you kind of as a
viewer grateful for like I can get a
nice meal I can take a shower I can't
have a bed the the basics of Life are
are quite accessible at least here for
us so you know those
resonate and then create an even better
contrast when you're back out in the
cold and you're camping in the dark and
you're trying to eat rabbits and stuff
yes yeah yeah
great in the way it lets you live in it
and I'm sure that the game didn't didn't
do this but I wanted Ellie she yelled at
that girl in the summer camp room was
like what are you looking at like I
wanted Ellie to find kind of another
friend again like a girl who was a
friend to sort of maybe talk to her
about like so what do you think like are
there like boys that I don't know what
the girl would say but she's in a
commune she might want to know more
about how Ellie got the way that she is
and I would have found that conversation
very intriguing and or hilarious
absolutely because Ellie is like a
little replica of Joel and she would
have been like I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about girl but like
you need to get it together do you want
to go like hunting like I just would
have liked to see that with Ellie and
not a normal girl but a girl who's in
the commune and thinking about how Ellie
was saying it's weird how she's thinking
about skirts and shoes and boys and
feelings when Ellie's like I just need
to survive I would have liked to see
that contrast with her yeah have her
find like a peer who has grown up here
but also knows this kind of more normal
lifestyle yeah instead of just alt fedra
and labs and qz stuff yeah yeah for sure
yep but across the board like really
nice character beats really nice
acknowledgment of the history you know
Joel withholding the information about
tests then it coming out later like all
those things felt very natural uh his
you know Reflections on and reluctance
to talk about Sarah just the way they
they have that little Memorial like all
those things feel so lived in and yeah
like the Great Moments between Joel and
Tommy especially and they had me going
like I thought like maybe maybe the next
episode will be a Tommy episode or
something like that like you know they
as much as you're like no Joe and Ellie
probably at the back of your mind you're
like they have to continue on at the
same time I'm you know they draw this in
a way where I'm like but anything could
happen you know yeah like him lying
there bleeding out I'm like if I
if hey that he
going to be dead because HBO does those
kinds of things they do they do and
that's yeah it's like you can never get
too calm but uh but so far this has been
terrific and this was yeah this was a
really interesting feeling episode yeah
because so much of it is about
warming up to letting yourself you know
be open to you know a little bit of
warmth and letting your guard down and
you know kind of opening back up and
yeah you understand the reluctance on
Joel's part especially and I just
continue to love the way that he and
Ellie go back and forth and have
friction in the way that she is pulling
him slowly out of his his cave and next
time we gotta get Joel singing a song we
need some Joel musical numbers I expect
a musical episode I bet you it's gonna
happen I'm gonna make I'm gonna make a
guess I bet you it's going to happen
when they're there and they're doing
some vaccine thing but Ellie is like
having a tough time maybe she's like
almost gonna die they're taking her
blood I don't know but she's like almost
maybe going to die and Joel starts to
sing to her yes yes there you go sings
her back to life you can cry him back to
life in the beginning of the next one he
can sing her back to life later
well Hells yeah Tara Erickson is there
anything you want to say to the people
before we Boogie no accepted I love you
we love you so be well thank you guys
for being so cool as always leave your
thoughts down in the comments below no
spoilers but you know that you guys are
Jiggy big you're so money baby leave a
like subscribe check out the patreon and
last but not least let's end this with a
patron of the day shout out
pandemic and demagoons I'm surprised we
haven't got to you on the last of us yet
but you are the one I mean you know you
could be patient zero with the name like
pandemic Jones or you could be the guy
to call in a pandemic and who knows what
to do yeah so another person whom we
would like to join our apocalypse
Survivor party you are invited as long
as you're cool with me Kanye Pandy I
think that is a that is a benefit like
you can Jones you can listen right there
sure right good company you know
supplies water food also nickname Pandy
yeah so uh from now on you're Pandy and
uh your Grandy and we are happy to have
you here at the patreons stay pledged
buddy and uh we'll catch you next let's
get Randy
Randy with Pandy that's your new podcast
style
you got is it adult theme yeah
see you next month
[Music]